you see Avatar no you didn't see it yet
no ah [ __ ] you went to a theater I did I
went to one I went there in Calgary they
have this new theater it's called a VIP
Theater so you know I had to be there
and it's only for two people I'm not
going to the ga theater yeah okay VIP
only
no yeah no it's just you walk into the
regular theater but they put a red rope
in front of the [ __ ] entrance Cody's
like I need to get in there now you walk
in and it's just a Samsung fridge yeah
in the middle of the room
with a lazy boy in front of it
hell yeah
let's go yeah
I picked that up Ryan picked that up
Ryan I'm thirsty
you guys can't see it but I just can't
can you get that for him please someone
on audio if you're listening on audio I
just I just can't
quite I see it's getting away from me oh
he had to enter
through the door yeah
there you go oh thank you yeah it was
still the same old dust though guys New
Year same us you know
yeah knew that was gonna happen
yeah sometimes I made too much money I
don't I'm stupid
I forgot to drink water
what do I do I can't even relate to Noel
anymore he doesn't know how to drink
water I just I'm so rich people drink
water for me yeah
I don't have to drink my own water
anymore yeah Ryan can you take a sip of
that
and then IV drip feed it from your
bladder into mine no the movie was fine
better than the first one we watched the
first one before
on the day no no no no not on on the day
but the day before okay or two days
before so yeah there's a lot of hours of
Avatar that we watched over the holidays
yeah I heard that
premise-wise they're pretty similar
uh
uh kind of have you seen it yeah
the first one is much more like would
you say it's still like humans yeah yeah
but it's way more focused on like
killing Jake Sully yeah you know
like the first one is more like oh we
got the resources and the you know the
the you know the people that are on the
planet already who cares about them we
got to get the resources yeah and this
one is more like Revenge
I just always thought of Avatar one
as like uh
uh a guy a short guy living a better
life when he becomes tall
yeah that's
that's a distilled version but yeah that
is what it is nice yeah nice yeah yeah
puns yeah but it it is kind of that
definitely and then the second one is
like all his haters coming after him
thank you
he's like so what I'm [ __ ] tall now
yeah they're like you're not allowed to
do that yeah
you're too cool we have to kill you
you're too hot it is pretty convenient
how at the end of the first one he like
merges and like becomes permanently an
avatar yeah he becomes six nine and then
he gets with uh what's her name how am I
Zoe Saldana Zoe Saldana yeah an ale a
triple A List actor yeah okay dude
what's the relatable part of this story
yeah yeah
the short guy becomes tall and lives
happily ever after with Zoe Saldana
Court
he's like paralyzed
even if he wasn't
friends even if he wasn't though okay
yeah even if he was able-bodied yeah
yeah and who knows he might have been
short that's what I'm saying like how
tall is he 510 yeah exactly there you go
yeah four king short
yeah then it becomes Seventeen four
and he becomes a king yeah he does he
becomes like the most respected Warrior
how what kind what kind of
you know what kind of Pocahontas story
is that
that is kind of [ __ ] up nine to ten
feet tall
yeah no wonder he cleaned up who's the
white guy and who's the white guy in the
Pocahontas story
in the Disney movie I have no idea yeah
whatever the [ __ ] Andrew or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah David
Christopher Columbus
who is he
John Smith I was confusing with Jon Snow
I will say the the like the like
visually the second one with all the
water it's [ __ ] beautiful it really
is should wash it on shrooms
I was with someone yesterday who did
exactly that yeah
he's like we're gonna go to Avatar too
taking some shrooms it's kind of fun
have fun nightmare by the way nightmare
nightmare yeah
laughs
[Laughter]
probably would be a good idea
uh did you find that like the scene
where they're yes like capturing and
killing the whale thing like scarring
like for for someone who jokes about
animal murder a lot on this podcast they
had like a 30 minute long scene of them
like snagging this whale you didn't want
to be a part of it I I was like repulsed
felt horrible to watch that but imagine
how easy a lobster would just yeah yeah
Avatar
yeah yeah the issue was that the animal
was like a fantasy animal yeah so I felt
like more connected to it real life yeah
lobsters yeah no it was it was decent it
was pretty good I want I'll watch it in
a couple days and then I saw Glass Onion
that [ __ ] stank I dude we wouldn't watch
the original knives out after that like
a million times better I watched the
first five minutes of Glass Onion and
turned it off dude horrendous that is
terrible so [ __ ] bad I couldn't
believe it did they kiss in the movie
Ryan Ryan liked it I loved it was there
any kissing there's
not really
at first you still liked it was
like why the [ __ ] was covid a part of
this movie why because they shot it
during who gives a [ __ ] yeah who cares I
don't want to see that [ __ ] anymore
I don't want to see we live through that
I don't want to see it in the movies
that I watch
like there are like half the [ __ ]
first hour is Daniel Craig in a mask
he's a beautiful man I want to see his
[ __ ] face that's like the first five
minutes what that's like the first five
no so 20 minutes
20 minutes
Cody also doesn't believe in the vaccine
no but you know you were frustrated by
that it's just the dog the dog scene one
scene
why was it there what what did it what
did it provide for the movie what did it
give to the story this is nothing
this is so good yeah no I I agree I I
just I rolled the first five minutes
because it just felt this is a stupid
setup
I I prefer if the movie lived in this
the first one was didn't have anything
to do with modern times right it was
just a story of yeah people trying to
kill each other yeah yeah I hate when
films now are just too close to real
life like when they're showing people
texting and covet and this very like
obvious nod to [ __ ] Elon Musk yeah
guys like I don't like that this guy's a
genius I get facts and
Uber yeah the first ad the first one's
good because like there's a there's like
a clear protagonist yeah it's like
you're rooting for
Anna De armas that's her name right yeah
her character you're rooting for her
because she's clearly like a really good
person yeah you know how much the the
father liked her and but this one you
hate everyone sucks
no what oh she was good the main chick
Janelle Monae spoiler alert this movie
stinks the fact that I didn't even
remember her character just now like she
didn't really leave that much of an
impact on me what and don't you think
the pacing was I hated how they kept
talking about the vaccine like it
doesn't
it doesn't like work
I I just really didn't like it I thought
I was really excited for it and then
didn't like it